expecting to see more strikes there as
well with the transport salaried staffs
Association saying that nine rail
operating companies as well as Network
rail will participate in a 24-hour
strike on Monday the 26th of September
that two is overpay job security and
what workers say is poor working
conditions now as we know many workers
have already been in talks with network
rail about the possibility of a
settlement and are now putting pressure
on transport secretary Grant chaps to be
able to come up with some sort of
solution as they say that he is the one
that is not being able to sort of come
to the table and come up with some sort
of solution but they're not alone as
union bosses across the country are now
fighting for better pay and better
conditions for their members we are now
in a cost of living crisis in Britain
saw the rate of inflation hit a fresh
40-year high in August alone own so many
cash strike families across the country
will be struggling and union bosses are
now fighting for their pay